yah welcome to this video against the
matzo pant cat from Australia and we got
the ever popular salam which I'm going
to battle with my queen bee three move
yeah this is this is rather okay for
black mmhmm yeah okay I'm going to go
inform people really know nowadays that
if I've is a good news here and I really
don't have anything against it but
nobody does so if he goes if I've that's
it I mean not like I'm losing but I
cannot really do anything about it
interesting I am they know nowadays that
this is a good line
now this is a very modest reply here but
okay I really don't don't know something
right down queen bee three or how it's
played actually tend to forget it
can i play a 4 and keep this part is
this ultimately too greedy
I'm not completely convinced that this
is not possible so let's do it I mean he
has come some compensation for sure with
my weekend squares there on d-4d three
things like long castles and Bishop c4
there is some compensation yeah this is
kind of this kind of thing p3 know that
looks very weakening let's just see to
develop stuff check okay here i get to
Castle long at least
okay so I think if he goes Bishop to be
four years chances to trade like a trade
to opposite colored bishop so let's go a
3m I really don't don't think that this
is full compensation I mean I love the
bishops as you know but I don't reject
the chatter this is sufficient hear this
in this situation okay do I go f5 g4 and
stuff like that how do i play him not
sure about this I should play that in a
in a slow way or and I know okay let's
check trade him trading the dog squad
bishops would be would be great
obviously but I don't see how to try to
maneuver my bishop to before or
something like that okay I'm thinking
about 92 to deform trying to improve
this night if you go see five is giving
up the d5 square so always trading that
I did not expect so now we have a pure
bishop end game and one where we've been
f this 55 with some three majority okay
to be gold medal for
a 4 p-3 p3 he might go see form ff4
ok let's start with that not entirely
sure okay check
can be forking c2 c4 maybe that's
something am at something
check
go there then I'm pushing the the King
side come check yeah my D se6 here e six
takes Bishop g7 that should be quite
good check
f6 I go five
chicks chicks I mean like King somewhere
King c4 I am ok just taking him G for a
3g five young can after after nothing
much else them okay now I can actually
think of be sure to d2 but ok is going
is going a three that could be could be
tricky but I really don't don't see him
down time morning I don't see anything
here why I'm not able to do that hm I go
King go King be too
I hope I'm not miscalculating stuff iam
so he's coming to you for them that's
not so great but it's really it doesn't
matter really I'm breaking the seven
blockade
now king of three I can't even play age
three and let him spend all that time
with the pawns
black resides John I don't know that was
a all-around tricky and game I wonder a
bit about the opening I really don't
remember i know that if i was perfectly
good but something something was a
little bit wrong here what does the what
was wrong i think yeah you know and i
think he should not take here nigel is
the rightness now that is better that is
better because now i don't really have
the time to play a form a player for
years got between him and if I teach a
cake that's a much better version as now
my bishop is no doubt and again I'm not
able to play that with a clear
conscience yeah yeah I really agile I
just have this move I think mean it's
not completely easy but it is a pawn and
it's not so apparent how is going to get
compensation check i think here it's
quite clear that there is nothing
substantial yeah III was mostly to
prevent opposite colored bishops for all
check check check it all looks very
normal just some strengthening move
check was very surprised that he did it
took only two that looked her like very
yeah cooperative let's say i should have
played this year that was probably a bit
better maybe be fine b3 a six and i'm
pushing him Jay I'm not sure if white
should win yeah maybe but check and try
that
yeah I always have this this idea yeah
that's at least very decent practical
chances but i'm not sure if it's a win
possibly just wrong yes and look be
three define chat Higgs yeah I was
expecting a cheeks but I'm not sure
about it Jeff to play like this
definitely controlling all those squares
and now is chad is coming I mean I think
here he is lost Thank You black is
losing the other engine agrees that
gives a complete win here for what my
pocket my pawns are just a bit a bit too
much there oh the computer gives King a
to as much better don't know why why is
this so much better because of this and
this I ok now that that idea was not yet
in my mind only later yeah ok that
that's understandable but it still
should win I mean would be kind of
surprising if not the efficiently twist
the right move takes and I'm satisfied I
think it was a decently played endgame
at least the comp doesn't find any
apparent improvement ok well thanks for
watching